hi guys I'm Eric Voss and here at new
rockstars we like to give you some deep
insights and the movies and TV shows
that we love at a depth of obsessive
paranoia that senior people don't bother
with and while we're proud of the work
we do here sometimes the massive volume
of stuff that we cover or just by
thinking about this stuff too hard and
giving ourself nosebleeds we missed the
mark all right now overshoot it by a few
planets so was the year comes to a close
I thought it would be fun to look back
at the biggest and weirdest stuff that
we got wrong theories that went too far
and the tumbles down the rabbit holes
that ended in hard rock bottom and to be
clear I'm not apologizing
I retract nothing this stuff is hard I
don't have time to sleep seriously
there's a creepy clown just in and off
camera whose only job is to squirt me
with seltzer and screaming my face if I
ever not off okay okay I'm weak I'm weak
and spoiler warning for any of the stuff
we cover here Thor Ragnarok Game of
Thrones Rick and Morty Justice League
stranger things Walking Dead legion we
covered all that stuff right here we go
v debunked theories number 5 Justice
League Alfred Pennyworth will die at
last summer's Comic Con a beefy new
trailer for Justice League came out and
if you remember it ended with this
cryptic tease and how our imaginations
ran wild and our breakdown philip and
sam speculated that Alfred is probably
talking to Superman but then they wrote
this that train a few more stops a lot
of people think that shoulders not red
it's brown like Hal Jordans flight
jacket maybe Alfred has been tasked with
hiding a mother box and this is him
staring down Steppenwolf like a badass
other big guest considering that this
character has a movie coming soon - is
Captain Marvel aka Shazam aka Billy
Batson the red shoulder could be from
the red on his costume brainwashed
Superman or not it feels like this could
be the last we see of Alfred in the DC
EU okay you know I don't blame those
guys at all for running with this but
the problem is this shot wasn't even in
the movie like many shots we saw in
those trailers this was left on the
cutting room floor as Joss Whedon Rochon
re-edited major section Zack Snyder's
original footage so while Alfred might
have been the one to dodge a bullet here
I do agree with those guys that this was
probably going to be the resurrect of
Superman meeting Alfred in that scene
there was the way Alfred punctuated hope
hope and really give him what we know
about the plot now there was really no
one else Alfred could have been talking
to Green Lantern Shazam and evil little
Superman weren't really as much part of
the story as some of us thought they
could be okay I wanted to get Pip and
Sam's slight misfire out
way because the rest of these are all me
baby and let's start with a real Cringer
number four stranger things second
season the monster is bar so in 2017 the
anticipation for stranger things second
season was high with lots of speculation
over what this new mysterious monster
was over the months i theorize that the
possible influence this could include
the DND monster that vessel Hydra that
was teased at the end of season one also
the HP Lovecraft II and characters like
Cthulhu or Nyarlathotep also more
obscure monsters like the Eldrazi from
Magic the Gathering or the amygdala from
the game blood-borne but those are all
names that are too hard for me to
pronounce over and over so here was my
final hot take what if this vessel Hydra
monster is barred ooh good joke younger
boss hey nice beaver shirt make sure to
wear that in every video okay you know
what I wasn't the most off the mark barb
totally was part of stranger things to
just mourn an off-screen dead kind of
way meanwhile we learned in the final
episodes that this monster's closest
parallel was the mind flayer from D&D
and hear interested more of my stranger
things obsession actually dug up 80 80s
references and other videos so go check
out that breakdown wanna get a chance ok
next up number 3 Rick and Morty the
return of evil Morty in 2017 new rock
stars began to cover my favorite
animated show on TV right now rick and
morty pointing out all the subtle jokes
of scare references and yes some hidden
Dickey's in the animation and the
biggest twist came in episode 7 of the
third season an episode that focused on
the Citadel of Rick's from various
dimensions which featured the return of
the mysterious season 1 character dubbed
evil Morty a corrupt politician who
becomes the evil president of the
Citadel
this was a huge bombshell for fans and
validation that are obsessive theorizing
that evil Morty was behind everything
wasn't a waste of time it's still kind
of us and because we love too much of a
good thing we all predicted that evil
Morty would return in the season finale
turning Rick and Morty's world upside
down the way this season finale is for
seasons one intuitive I predict that the
president that the episode description
promised Rick would meet is actually the
newly elected president of the Citadel
evil Morty who will have some secret
plot against this president perhaps
using this infestation of googas
infestation of googas now when I predict
these wrongly it's like I have to sound
as stupid as possible also Jung Hwa's
good work keeping that beaver shirt
relevant and you ever watch it
instead the season finale was a much
more straightforward
with Rick and Lorie battling the
American president for a selfie and Rick
allowing the Smith family to reset to a
state of relative normal seat it's like
we forgot the creators Justin roiland
and Dan Harmon aimed to turn the world
of the show upside down and pretty much
every episode and letting fans force
them into bending their crazy animated
adventure into a more serious long-term
political thriller what that game of
thrones type villain isn't it all what
Rick and Morty is all about that said I
still kind of believe evil Morty is what
Rick and Morty was all about actually
it's making the Game of Thrones let's
move on to number 2 on our list Game of
Thrones
Ozora hi the prince that was promised is
Jamie Lannister
now back before we got neck deep in Game
of Thrones Season 7 breakdowns in
Westeros weekly recaps I made a video
sharing the theory that came upon line
that the ultimate hero of Game of
Thrones could very well be Jaime the
Kingslayer
the theory involved linking parts of
Jaime's story with the legend of azor
Ahai combining them with some choice
selected bits of dialogue from the show
in the books all yielding this lil Jam
Lightbringer doesn't refer to a literal
sword but Jamie's golden hand bursting
into flames as he chokes Cersei causing
literal ashes to form in her mouth now I
know you're gonna say this is still
possible right there's still six
episodes left they could do this don't
do that to me don't get baby's hopes up
the events of seasons have made it
pretty clear who the heroes of Game of
Thrones will be Dany and John aka Aegon
Targaryen United in battle against the
White Walkers in the night cave and it's
time to expand increasingly doubtful
that these old prophecies from the
backstory on the show and the books will
come into play and suddenly be relevant
in the final six episodes like I think
other supporting players like Jaime and
Tyrion and Arya will definitely have big
roles to play but I don't think the
writers will make time to deliver on a
barely plausible fan theory about hot
hands and our final wrong Theory number
one on our list this soulstone the final
infinity stone is with Heimdall and thor
ragnarok
so with the trailer of Avengers infinity
war now in our lives the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is hunt for the
Infinity stones it's become something we
all care about now not just us nerds
last year Doctor Strange revealed the
second to final infinity stone the green
time stone in the eye of agamotto after
that point a theory emerged about the
location of the final final stone the
soul stone dice tied into wholeheartedly
the idea was that the first letter of
each of the sources of the first five
Infinity stone
were t-s-a oh and and which when
rearranged give you the name Thanos with
the H missing that H could refer to
Heimdall now he is blind but he has the
ability to seize souls wherever they are
in the universe and having the soul
stone in his head could be how he does
that and by his eyes appear to be orange
leaving it up to Thor Ragnarok as the
most likely film to reveal it Oh even
younger bedroom boss why did you yell so
much
of course I'm doll didn't have these
soul stone and thor ragnarok Heimdall
was barely in Thor Ragnarok Ragnarok
didn't really give a about the
Infinity stones and sure this theory
sounded good at the time except for the
fact that and would have had to have
been for the eye of agamotto necklace
and no one ever called it a necklace
guys it's just easy to look over these
things when you're blinded by these
sexiness acronyms and to wrap things up
now for your home viewing pleasure let's
close out with some behind the scenes
footage of the screw-ups we make while
recording these videos because when
remember we'll remember when well of
wow-wow for dough booty room remember
when Ralph is told he's getting his very
own super scoop there's no scooting that
soon I know Hugh Jackman said Logan was
his final Wolverine movie but come on
he's got a drop-by I can't do Australian
hey if the plants want to take a page
out of arrows Burke boo York boo York
and yes the bullet ooh when you don't
talk all day a little magical frog
crawls out of your lungs up in Deer
larynx and gives you cancer and that's
why kids you should never stop talking
what good would they be look I'm leaving
it
the difference is Kyle Oh makes his
something just happened here my
computer's going crazy there's a ghost
in my computer
there's ghosts everywhere I'll see you
guys next time
farts I'm out Eric doesn't do this when
he has enough sleep Eric only does this
when he has no sleep Eric is going crazy
whatever just let's just go to bed yeah
you know it's just not as clean between
takes
shut up thank you for watching this and
be sure to subscribe the new rock stars
to get honestly far more accurate and
OnPoint theories about that properties
you love but sure also probably a few
more bogus far fetched theories and 2018
hit me up on Twitter at ei vas or
probably no rock stars on Twitter at new
rock stars for updates on their videos
thanks for watching guys bye